do you think people that want to be
useful today should get PhDs um mostly
not some with what is the best some yes
but mostly not how should someone figure
out how they can be most useful or
whatever this thing is that you're
trying to create what would what would
be the utility Delta compared to the
current state-of-the-art
times how many people it would affect so
that's why I think having something that
has a that that has a mix makes a big
difference but effects a sort of small
to moderate number of people is great as
is something that makes even a small
difference but but affects a vast number
of people like the area yeah on you know
under the oh yeah exactly the area under
the curve is would actually be roughly
similar for those two things so it's
actually really about yeah just trying
to be useful and matter when you're
trying to estimate probability of
success so you say something will be
really useful good area under the curve
I guess to use the example of SpaceX
mmm-hmm when you made the go decision
that you're actually going to do that
this was kind of a very crazy thing at
the time very crazy there shortly yeah
I'm not shy about saying that but I kind
of agree I agreed with them that it was
quite crazy crazy if if the objective
was to achieve the best risk adjusted
return starting our company is insane
but that was not that was not my
objective
you